を確定する サティパッターナナっていうのは確定する
気づくこと しっかりする
自分のものにする だから自分の生活において気づくっていうことは
自分のものにするということで
サティパッターナっていう意味なんですね
で そこは 4つありますと
で あの まあ気づくことを確定しましょう
ただそれだけ言うと まあいい加減で
どんな人にも自分勝手な解釈できるようになってしまうんですね
気づくと言えば もうよく一般的な世の中で知っている言葉なんですね
ではそれはしっかりしましょう
確定しましょうと というと
それまた一般的な言葉になっちゃうんですね
だからこの まあそうはしないで
やっぱりきちんと定義を持って
どのように確定するかという
そこら辺もまた明確にはっきりするんですね
ですから あの そういうことでカメチャッタロ
チャッタロサティパッタナナ
4つありますよと言うんですね
で この仏教において このあるもう一つの特色なんですけど
このお釈迦様おっしゃった言葉の
まあ一部だけいわゆるこの頭の項目行だけ取ってみると
大変かっこいい 素晴らしい言葉なんですね
だからみんなよく分かります
よく分かりますと言うんです
で ものすごい普遍的で
すごいかっこいい ものすごい洗練されてる言葉なんですね
今言ったようにも やっぱり人間っていうのはもう気づくことは確定しなくちゃいけないんだと言えば
まあこれはもうその通りやと
みんな偉そうに思っちゃうんですね
で 世の中で仏教って人気あるのは
ただそこまでなんです
理解できるのはそこまでだから
だから一般的なテキストとかね
まああるいは色々学者とかね
例えばキリスト教にしたっても
キリスト教の仏教学者がいますからね
そういう人々も決して仏教っていうのは悪いものだと思ってないんです
すごい教えだと で どこまでかというと
このお釈迦様おっしゃった言葉の一部までで知って
そこで終わっちゃうんですね
だからここを見ても まあもう
サティパッターナですよと
まあ気づくことを確定すれば
人間には苦しみも悩みも憂いも
もう何もなくなっちゃいますよと
正しく道に入れば正しく生きていられますよと
それはまあ それなりに意味があるんです
語っているのは真理だから
事実だから 間違ってるわけではないんですね
でも 大雑把で世俗的に好き勝手にいい加減に解釈して
そこを実践してみたんだからと
お釈迦様が体験したおっしゃっている
あのしっかりした解脱の方向へ行くということはないんですね
お釈迦様は知識に代わりにこの智慧というものをおっしゃってますから
だからその智慧の方に行くためには
もうちょっとお釈迦様に話を聞かないと
どのようにすればいいかと
ですから 世の中で我々一般的にまあ気づき
気づきという風な意味ではなくて
特別に 4種類の気づきがありますよと
それは 4種類ですよと言って
その定義もお釈迦様はなさるんですね
今日からその 4つ 4種類の気づきって何ですかと
4種類のところで  4つのところで気づき
気づくことを確定しなくちゃならないんだと
まあ 1番目はカーエーカーヤーノパッシーヴィヘレティ
アターピーサンパジャノサティマヴィネイヤローケアビッジャドーマナッサン
で カーエー まあ自分 カーヤっていうのは体
それからカーヤは何ですか？と
それからまた定義入りますけど
今の説明見ると カーエー
体において カーエーアヌパッシー
カーヤアヌパッシー 体に沿って見ていてくださいと
いわゆる体に従って見てください
アヌパッシーっていうのは
例えば体を観察すると
体はどのように行動して
どのように動いているかって
それに沿って観察するということ
逆に体をいじるっていうことではなくて
体を放っておいて 体に沿って観察していってくださいと
だからカーヤーアヌパッシー
だから もう体を気づくことの対象にする
そうすると体を切って貼って
いろんなことを自分でいろいろやるんではなくて
カーヤアヌパッシー 体にアヌパッシー
体に沿って体はどのようなものかと
もう まあ外からいわゆる客観的に観察するという意味で
カーヤーアヌパッシーという言葉を使ってるんですね
だからここでサティ 気づくこと確定しなさいと言ったっても
こちらではっきりと言ってるのは
まあ体に沿ってまあ知ってがってというとちょっと意味が変わりますけど
うーん  動きのままに 動きのままに
そうですね 動きのままにっていう意味でもいいかもしれません
ですから あまりどこにも定義解釈はしないだろうと思いますけど
その言葉にはね ですから
カーヤヌパッシーっていうのは大変大事な言葉なんですね
だから別に余計にダブっているわけではないんです
カーヤヌパッシー・ヴィーリティだけでいいんじゃないかなと
そうでもなくて やっぱりカーヤっていうもうもう体はサティの修行対象になって
認識対象になって それで体のままに動きのままにさせて観察していくという
まあ私はこの客観的にっていうのはそういう意味なんですね
うん で ヴィーリティ それだけであるとアータピ
かなり努力しなくちゃいけないんですね
だからいい加減じゃダメなんですね
アータピというのはかなり真剣にって意味なんですね
これタパスいわゆる修行というにも使っている同じ言葉なんですね
だからまあ修行の感じでという意味で修行しているつもりで
もうかなり真剣に だからアータピというのはこのタパスだから
この修行という意味でもあるし
タパスというパーリ語はサンスクリット語のタパスという言葉から出ていて
このサンスクリット語
パーリ語っていうのは動詞からできていますから
これタパスというのは燃やすという火という意味なんですね
燃えるという意味なんですね
だからこの燃えるという言葉から修行という言葉を使っているんですね
で じゃあ燃えるって何が燃えるかというと
やっぱり人間っていうのは普通は欲に溺れてだらしない性格
心を持ってるんですね
この悪いものを燃やしちゃいましょうというのが
インド一般的な宗教世界では言っているものなんですね
体は汚れて心が汚れているんだと
この汚れを燃やそうと
そういうことで宗教そのうち苦行にもなってしまっちゃったんですね
で タポタポということは
中村元先生は苦行 苦行だとも訳するし
それで仏教の修行においても何のことなく苦行とか
そこは間違いし なさらば苦行ということはお釈迦様使ってないんだからね
ですからこのでも修行にはタパスという言葉を使うんですね
そういうことで まあそれインド的にインドの文化である言葉で
ですから修行といえば何か燃やすという大変な仕事
簡単な仕事ではない 何を燃やすかというと
心の汚れを燃やすと ですから意味はもうかなり真剣真面目にということなんですね
修行を通して観察しなきゃいけないんですね
修行だから心清らけになることは目的としてしているんです
ただ単に面白い おかしくということではないんです
体に沿って体の動きのままに観察するんだけど
これは修行であると これでもって心はしっかり伸ばしてきれいにしてやるぞというぐらいの真剣さですね
アターピー 次の言葉はサンパージャーノ
で あの サンパジャーンっていうのは
これはアウェアネスとこの日本訳英訳する言葉なんですね
で アウェアネスあるいはコンプリヘンションという言葉を使いますし
サンパジャーンっていうのは大変これ訳しにくい言葉なんですね
サンパジャーンっていうのは
この目覚めている状態
いわゆるこのボーっとしてる状態のものすごい反対なんです
普通 ボーっとしているとボケしているのは普通ですけど
そちらの反対 ものすごいこの心を目覚めて
物事を感知しつついる状態なんですね
ですからアウェアネスという英訳になっているんですね
いわゆるこの知りつつなんですね
いつでも今何が起きているかという
自分の周りに起きている出来事について
これから体のことだから
体に起こる出来事についていつでも目覚めているんですね
いつでももう注意深くよく知っている状態
だから これには適切な日本語はあるかどうかちょっとね
思い浮かばないんですね
大体ないでしょうと思いますけどね
だから似ている言葉あるんだけど
どうもこの使う道がおかしいんですね
例えば注意深くとかね
注意 一般的には注意ぐらいのことなんですけどね
だから日本だったら気を付けるということもまた同じ意味でダブってしまっちゃうんです
だから注意深くなんですけど
これ理解につながってるんですね
だから理解しつつ 分かりつつという
だから目覚めている状態でいいと思いますけどね
常に目覚めている状態
それはサンパジャーンっていう言葉なんです
サティが次に出てくるんですね
サティマン それで次に気付きがある人というあるということ
いつでも気付きがあって
体に体について気付きがあるだけではなくて
いつでも目が覚めている状態で観察し続けなくちゃいけないんですね
目覚めた状態で その目覚めた状態ないと悟りにはいかないんです
ただ気付いただけで ただラベリングしただけでは悟れません
もう一つ人間に能力が必要なんですね
それはどのように育てるかって
これはどうしようもないんです
気をつけろというぐらい注意しよう
注意しなさいというぐらいなんですね
だからこの私は時々ひらめきという言葉も使います
しますし 例えば何か研究していくと
いろんな情報 データを調べて調べていっても
調べただけで研究ではありません
データ集めただけで研究ではありません
データ集めて調べて分類して並べたっても
もう大したことはないんです
大体この文化系だったら
ほとんど研究って大体そんなもんなんですね
で 科学でも まあ初期時代の科学っていうのは
自然科学の場合はほとんどデータいろいろ集まるだけで
でももう一つ何かあるんですね
何かひらめくと ただ無差別にデータだけ集める人にとっては結論のようなもの
だから何ですかと これはというそれには答えられないんですね
ですから この理解していることですね
だから何ですかと聞いたら
こういうことですよと説明できるところは
このサンパジャーンナなんですね
ですから サティとサンパジャーンナというのはいつでも一緒
仏教の修行においてはサティだけではもう何にもならないんですね
だからサンパジャーンナ育てようと思って
いろんな余計なことを考えたりしちゃうと飛んじゃうんですね
現在から あ こうではないか
こうだと思ったとか もう事実から飛んでるんですね
すぐ頭の中だけの回転で飛んでしまっちゃうんです
ですから そこら辺もダメなんですけどね
で 事実から飛ぶこともできない
良くないんだけど やっぱり何か理解しなくてもならないんです
で サティは次に出てきて
それからヴィネイヤローケアビッジャードーマナッサンという行
まあローケっていうのは廊下世界という意味なんですけど
世界っていうのは人生においてっていうのは
生き方においてありとあらゆるものにおいてというふうに
生き方においてアビッジャーっていうのは余計な
ものすごく恐ろしい 根拠もない欲と
またはドーマナッサっていうのはもう苦しみも悩みもあって
怒りなんですね で あの
まあやっぱりこちら まあ憂いぐらいで訳してますから
それぐらいの意味でも構いません
アビッジャーっていうのはすごく貪欲で
まあ欲なんですね それからドーマナッサっていえば憂いなんですけど
まあ欲ある人に欲出るものですからね
悲しみっていうのは悩みっていうのは
物事もうけないと やっぱりいろいろ心の中で悩み
悲しみ 苦しみが生まれてくるんですね
まあ一般的に言えば 欲と怒りを捨てなさいということなんですね
ですから ヴィネイヤっていうのはコントロールしなさいと
そこでこの普通の生き方言ってるんですね
体に沿って体の動きのままに見ている
それでまたものすごく常に目が覚めている状態があって
それでサティという気付くということをよく持っていて
生活する それだけではなくて
もう一つやらなくちゃいけない
この世の中に 世の中において
怒りと欲と怒りを抑えておきなさいと
ですから この行で このことによって怒りと欲が消えてしまいますよと
怒りと憂いが消えてしまいますよということを言っているわけじゃないんです
我々のこの生き方 あなたはこういうふうにやってくださいということなんです
ですから 心の中ですごく欲があると
いろんなことについて
心はものすごくこの混乱するんですね
欲っていうのはすごい巨大な膜なんですね
不透明な だから心に欲がすごい厚い膜を覆ってしまえば
何も観察できなくなるんですね
そうすると 欲のままに好き勝手に物事を見るんです
昨日そういう説明しましたけど
例えば食べ物に欲がある人は
どこへ行ってももうそこばっかり探してるんですね
昨日言ったことでもう一度言いますけど
まあグルメの人なんかね
たまに山でも遊びに行こうかなと山に引っ張っても
何か植物とか これはすごく美味しいですよとすぐ言っちゃうでしょうに
だから山の中 滝を見ながら動植物を見ながら遊ぶんではなくて
その人そこでも食い物を探しちゃうんですね
川見ていると そこであゆとかいろんな魚がいたら
ああ これ塩焼きにしたらすごく美味しいですよと
だから山に連れて行ったっても
その人は山を見てないんです
もう欲にすごい膜を心に膜がついているんだから
だから欲ある人は世の中見てないんです
自分の好き勝手に世の中を判断する
ですから 知る人にとっては欲がすごい邪魔なんです
だから人間関係であっても人を見えなくなっちゃうんですね
自分には何か欲があると
相手は自分の欲の眼鏡で見ているますね
自分には気に入るタイプか気に入らないタイプか
まずそこから見て それからその人と喋ったりする
ですから もう全然相手を理解するということは成り立たないんですね
人を理解することは一生ならないんですね
ただ 自分の好みに合う人々と喋って仲良くしているだけで
じゃあその人の気持ちはどういう気持ちかと
それもほとんど知らない
誰でも強引に親切にすると
その人のことは親切にはしますけど
だからといって 例えば私がある人のこと好きなんですけど
だからってその人が私のこと好きっていうことはありえないし
でもこちらはずっとしつこくもう責めると
向こうもそれなりに反応するかもしれませんね
そうやって強引な生き方なんですね
この世の中にあるのは
本当に人の心を理解しようということは成り立たないんですね
だから人間って まあ一般的にいろいろ欲が
欲にもいろいろ 例えば花が好きな人がいるとすると
まあどこに連れてその人はもうすぐ花探したりするし
食べ物に欲がある人は
まあもう山に連れて行ったっても
もうどこへ連れてってもどうしようもないんですね
まあ食い物しか考えませんしね
例えば犬好きな人がどこかのもうどこかに行ったと訪ねたとする
その行ったところで犬がいるんだったら
家の人と挨拶する先に犬を見て犬を可愛がるでしょうね
だからこの理解する人にとっては
欲っていうのは大変なもう心の膜になってしまっちゃうんですね
厚い膜を覆ったことになる
ですから そこは最初からもう自分で取り除いてくださいと
この実践方法をやりたければ
欲はもう最初から取り除いてほしいんです
それから憂いももう最初からもうないようにしてほしいんですね
ですから ヴィネーヤ そこは自分をコントロールしなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると正しく観察できるんです
まあそれぐらい 二番目はヴェーダナーす
同じこと ヴェーダナーのパス
ヴィーヘルと ヴェーダナーっていうのは体の感覚
体の感覚についてまた気づく修行をやっているんですね
その場合も感覚のままに
感覚はなんとか自分好き勝手にいじるんではなくて
それを放っておいて 感覚のままに観察していくんですね
その場合もサンパダーナも必要し
アビッジャードーマナスも当然なくさなくちゃいけないんですね
で 三番目はチッテー チッターヌパッシー
心において 心はなんとかいじろうではなくて
チッターヌパッシー 心のままに観察していくんですね
四番目はダンメーす ダンマーヌパッシー
ダンメーといえば その場によって意味が変わりますけど
だいたいこの場ではカーヤとヴェーダナーとチッて除いて他の諸々のことなんですね
体と自分の感覚と心だけ見たらもう完璧に自分を見ているんです
自分のこと だから自分のことを完璧に観察しているんだけど
またその他のいろんな諸々のこと世の中にあるんですからね
そういうものも全部まとめてちゃんと気付いてくださいと
ちゃんと理解能力持ちなさいと
だからどんなものにもよく目覚めている状態は守らなくちゃいけない
だから仏教を実践してみるとかなり頭が良くなるんですよ
良くならないはずないんです
世の中にはこれでいくと
あれはさっぱりわかりませんと
どうなってるんだい？そんなことない
どうなってる？すぐわかるんです
私はそういうことに興味ないとか
なんとか偉そうな格好つけて世界から逃げたりもする
それは弱いだけのことで
あなたに興味あるか関係ないかな？関係ないで
それも 例えばよく言うでしょ
私には今もう瞑想してるんだから
そういうものには興味ないんですよとかね
関係ないんですよとかね
それも結局自分の好き嫌いでしょうに
自分の好き嫌いで瞑想好きになって
瞑想でない世界はもう関係ないと
世の中で瞑想の世界だけじゃなくて
普通の人間の世界の方がもっと多いでしょうに
それに関係ないと言っちゃったらね
それは知恵につながるはずでもないんですね
ですから 気づくという awareness
ということ 目が覚めている状態っていうのは
その他もろもろのことについても実践しなくてはならないんですね
そうすると この限りなく知恵というものは
理解能力っていうのは広げていくんです
限りなくどんなものについてあっても
それいろんなものについて知恵って理解能力を広げたところで
じゃあ真実なんですかっていうことに目覚めることは可能なんですね
だからもう簡単単純な修行法でね
これも無制限に限りなく自分の理解能力というものは増えるような実践方法なんです
だから どっちにしたっても
自分の欲で見るんではないんだよ
欲は最初からもう置いといて
自分の好みを置いといて
世の中を見なくてはならないんですね
で 心の中で憂い悲しみがあると
またうまく心が動かないんですね
それは怒りに関係あるものですからね
ですから 欲と怒りは一応最初からもう抑えておけと
置いておけと 外しておきなさいと
心から外しておいてやってみればうまくいくんです
大体その四つですよと
この四つにまとめないものは何一つもないんです
入ってないものは この分類には
この分類に入ってないもの
何かあるかと 何もないんです
だから一般的な知識でテキストを読んでいる人だったら
それだけでもと これすごいと
世の中のことも どんなものについても目覚めて気づいていなさいと
お釈迦様おっしゃってるんだと
これはその通りですよと
よくわかりますよと言うんですけどね
よくわかるんだけど じゃあ悟ったんですけど
悟ったわけでもないんですね
ただ 仏教のブッダの言葉を評価するだけなんですね
評価するしか他のないです
批判することは不可能だからね
ブッダの言葉を批判したのは世の中でたった一つのグループだけなんです
一つはこのお釈迦様 仏教はこのインド文化に生えて
ヒンドゥ教に吸収されてから
2つの学派が出てきて
後で書いてあるテキストなんですけどね
このヨガはあれでした
今ちょっと思い出せないんだけどね
大変有名なテキストで
そこでこの一人の哲学者がこのヒンドゥ教の有名な人なんですけどね
古いテキストなんですし
これおそらく 7世紀もっとちょっと前かな
書かれたものなんですけど
まあブッダのブッダはヴィシュヌ神そのものであって
ヴィシュヌの化身ですよと
だからブッダが言っていることは
まあただのヒンドゥ教そのものですよと言う
その方が強力的で王政の人々そう信じているんですね
だから彼らにとっても批判できないんですね
ブッダが言っていることは間違っていると批判できないんだから
でも 一般的な上辺だけしか読んでないでしょうし
理解してないんですね
例えば 全ての物事についてはもう目覚めていなさいと言ったら
これはもう誰もダメとは言わないんだからね
良くないと思わないんだから
ですから この一般的に
まあブッダはヴィシュヌの化身だと
神の化身だと だからそういうふうに言ってるんだということで
結局教えは認めざるを得ない状態
もう一人の学派がもっとブッダの教えを読んでみたみたいですね
もうちょっと深く 要するに彼の反論はブッダは悪魔だと
だからこのヴィシュヌ化身であることを否定できません
みんなそう思ってるんだからね
そこでヴィシュヌの化身かもしれませんだけど
それで化身してブッダにそうして化身してきて
世の中はとことん惑わせてしまったと
頭の悪い連中を だから一応もう悪い人々を処分したいんだけど
明確に壊した方が処分しやすいんですね
そんな感じで世の中を惑わせるために現れてきたんだというふうに
ものすごく悪いことを言うんです
でも 私 個人的な感覚から見れば
そのお釈迦様はとんでもない悪魔だという人がもうちょっと読んでいるんですね
読んでいるんだから それでも否定できない
でもこれ実践しちゃったらヒンドゥー教にはならないんですね
魂信じるようにはならないんですね
みんな頭しっかりしている連中になってしまっちゃいますから
それは困るんですね 偉大なる魂を体験してほしいんですね
だからこんなこと迷惑だと
こんな教えがあったら
みんなこれ理解しちゃうんだと
この方向行っちゃうんだと
困ったもんだと でも自分にとっても否定できない
だからもうヴィシュヌが悪魔の形に来たんだというふうに
彼にとっては言うよもないんですね
他のいうほか ですから
そちらにもやっぱり認めざるを得ない状態に陥ったんですね
で 仏教の中から出てきた
この後で大乗仏教と名付けた世界だけなんですね
ブッダを否定できたのは
でも一つも理屈成り立ってないんです
正しく論理的にこういうわけでお釈迦様間違ってるよってことは言えないんです
ただ あっちこっち回りで回りでいろんな余計なことを言って
ブッダの教えを捨てちゃって
もう自分たちの勝手な教えを
寄生するんですね 仏教に
だからあれは寄生 寄生教みたいな感じで
仏教という大きな木の上で寄生しているんですね
ですから どれぐらい寄生してるかってことをはっきりと
ただ だからあの木の上に寄生植物はあるかないか分かるためには
この根元見て分からないんです
葉っぱ見た方が分かるんです
花見たら分かるんです
実を見たら分かるんです
全く違うんではないかと
例えばもうとことん念仏唱えなさいと
それしか道がないんだと
それこそ教えだということと
こういうことと見ると
ものすごい違うでしょうね
どうやって同じ木からこんな 2つの実が出てくるんですかと
不思議でたまらんでしょうに
だからこの あるいは南無妙法蓮華経って題目を唱えることこそ仏教
ブッダで教えだと どこにそんなものありますかね
例えば法華経読んでもたっても題目ってことないでしょうに
ないんです どんな大乗経典でもナマクサルナキナエという言葉から始まりますしね
世尊に礼をするとかね
法華経でもサンスクリット語だったらそういう風に始まるんですけど
あらっとなんか不思議で
南無妙法蓮華経 それは呪文であって
マンドラであって 宇宙の大マンドラであって
もう大変なこと それこそ道だと
あれ唱えてどうなるんですかね
アホにもなりますからね
もうそれみんなアホになっちゃったんだから
それしか道がないと じゃあ気づくことやら
常に世の中の出来事に目覚めていることやら
自分の体のことについてずいぶん研究していくことやら
何一つもないでしょう
ですから この そういう世界っていうのは寄生教なんです
同じところから発生してね
同じ木の根元から栄養をとってますけどね
ブッダがなければみんな死んじゃいますよ
悟りはありませんという人もいるし
悟りはもういりませんという人もいるし
もうとっくに悟ってるんだよという人もいるし
まあ無茶苦茶いろいろいるんですけどね
誰にしたってもね ブッダなければみんな死んじゃいます
だから私はまあ寄生教みたいな言葉
失礼な激しい言葉かもしれませんだけど
こちらはもうブッダの教えを勉強するところだからね
文句は聞きません だからそういうことを言いたいんです
他のところではそういうことは言いませんだけど
ですからまあ見るとそういうことではないかなとね
ですから その四つ見ると
我々は何がわかるかというと
自分に対して 自分というこの体に対して
体に対して体の感覚と心
その三つで自分というこのシステムは全部入るでしょうね
それについて明確に知恵を得るんですね
体について客観的に それで自分のことをわかっただけで全てわかったということを言うのはちょっと失礼だから
もろもろのことについても
それ以外のことについても
もうちょっとサティを働かせてみなさいと
ということで 四つの分類に入ってるんですね
すべてのものが そういうことでサティの実践に入らない
関係ない対象は一つもないんです
だからサティの実践にはこの善悪という判断できません
何かやめて 何かから逃げて
特別に何かするという世界ではないんです
何からも逃げません 世の中の出来事だから
それについて知恵を得ようとする
怒りは来てないとか 嫉妬は来てないとかね
私は清らかな心を作るんだとかね
そうやって偽善ばっかしでね
でね 人々はもうサティの世界には行かないんですね
そちらから逃げることはしません
堂々とぶつかって 直面して
そこについて知恵を得る
怒りについて知恵を得る
嫉妬について知恵を得る
で 世の中のことについても
堂々とそれを観察して
それから知恵を得る だから善悪判断やらいい悪いとかね
かっこいいかっこ悪いとか
そうやってこの二分化して物事を見るのは
この世俗的な世界で次元であって
現象の中に生きている人々の概念の中に生きている人々の次元なんですね
高いという概念を作ったら
高くないという概念が生まれてくるし
悪いという概念を作っちゃったら
その裏に必ずしも良いという概念があるし
そうやって二分化して概念が成り立ってるんですね
ほとんど まあそうやって二つに二つに分けて
だからそれはもう概念の世界で二つに分けちゃうと
一部が良くて一部が悪いということにもなってしまっちゃうんですね
そうすると悪いものから逃げて
いいものにもう逃げてしまうようなこっちゃいけないということもなっちゃうんですね
そこはもう大変なややこしい世界で
で ヴィパッサナーにおいては
サティにおいては そういう世界ではなくて
まあそのまま判断というのは置いておいて
客観的に見てみる 見て
そこから知恵を得ようとする
で そこまでで それからなんですが
さらに自己自分勝手に解釈に行っちゃいますから
さらに明確に体に沿ってどのように観察するかと
またやり方 もっと明確に明確に説明しているんですね
それで体の瞑想 カタム・チャ・ビッケーヴェー・ビックー・カーエー・カーヤーヌ・パッシー・ヴィーラティ
イデ・ビッケーヴェー・ビックー・アランニャ・ガトーワー・ルッカ・ムーラ・ガトーワー・スンニャー・カー・ガトーワー・ニッシーダ・ディ・パッランカン・アグ
・ウジトゥワー・ウジュンカーヤン・パニダーエ・パリムカン・サティン・ウパッタ・ペットゥワーというところまで
カタム・チャ・ビッケーヴェー・ビックー・カーエー・カーヤーヌ・パッシー・ヴィーラティ
体に沿って観察するのはどのようにやりますか？と
カタン どのように ハウ
ハウということ ビックー
比丘がどのように？カーエー・カーヤーヌ・パッシー・ヴィーラティ
体において 体ということを対象にして
体に沿ってどのように観察し得るかと
イデ・ビッケーヴェー・ビックー・アランニャ・ガトーワー・ルッカ・ムーラ・ガトーワー
そこでやり方を明確に書いているので
ここでビクがアランニャ・ガトーワー
森に入って あるいはルッカ・ムーラ・ガトーワー
あるいはどこかの木の下に行って
あるいはスンニャー・カー・ガトーワー
もう人はあまりない静かな何か建物
部屋の中に入ってという
いわゆるそこで言っているのは静かなところに行きなさいと
いろいろ面倒くさいところには出てきてできませんと
[背景音楽]だからあんまりうるさくて大変な激しいところではなくて
森の中か インドでは一般的だからね
森の中やらもう木の下やらね
もう人が住まない家っていうのはね
いくらでも一般的なところから
とにかくそうやって静かな場所に行きなさいと
いてニシーダティ 座る
パッランカン・アブジットワ
足を組んで座ると で この足を組んで座るというね
まあこれインドで始めたやり方で
一つは経済的には大変便利なんです
椅子なんかになっちゃうと
ものもう家具だから 機械だから
それで機械文化が発達するでしょう
どんなデザインか 木材はどんな木材でいいんですかとか
クッションはどのようなもの
どんなものを作ればいいですかどうか
インドではもうすごいそういう文化が発達していますし
ですから この椅子なんか使っちゃうとかなり問題なんですね
なぜならば 椅子っていうのは人が作ったものだから
気に入る気に入らないという関係もあるし
体に合う合わないっていうことも出てくるし
ややこしくなってしまっちゃうんですね
それでそんなこと何もなく
足を組んで座れと それだけでもかなり楽になってしまっちゃうんですね
だから経典で この戒律の世界では
このお寺にはいっぱい家具とかね
もらったりしたんですよ
特にブッダの場合はね
もうブッダの人間関係っていうのは
インドでは一番えらい高いレベルの高い階層の人々と随分仲良くしていたんだから
まあ王様の家族やらね
みんなもうみんな仲良くでしょうし
それで何回もこの王様の親戚が亡くなっちゃうと
この宮殿にあった家具ありったけのものそのままお寺に持っていっちゃうんですね
ある王様のおばあちゃんかな
おばあちゃん亡くなって
で その方住んでいた宮殿にあったもうカーペット
絨毯からもう全部もういろんな車に乗せてお寺に運ぶ
車に乗せてお寺に運ぶ
持っていってしまっちゃって
あげてしまっちゃったんですね
それでお坊さんたちにとっては
これ大変なことなんですね
なぜかっていうと 並のものじゃないんです
絨毯一つにしても 大変なものなんですね
そんなものはそのまま使っちゃうとお寺に泥棒が入っちゃうんです
であまりあまりの効果だから
泥棒がそんなに入ろうっていうこともありませんだから
なぜならば売れませんからね
どこへ売ったってすぐわかるでしょ
王様のものだからね それは売れません
それでも危ないでしょうし
まあ絨毯はそのまま使っちゃったんだけど
それでもやっぱりこの
あの 認めてない絵柄とかあるんだったら
そこら辺は切ってください
ブッダは認めてない絵柄とかあります
例えば欲的なね 男女の色々絵とかね
デザイン的に作ってんのは
それをもう切って捨てなさいと
いろんな花の模様やら
まあまあそれなりの動物の模様やら
デザイン的なものは それはまああまり
まあまあ放っておくんだけど
それから椅子の場合は
あの金を張ったりとかね
それからよくあったのは
この馬とかライオンとか虎とかね
そういう形で椅子を作るんで
今もあるで 椅子の脚なんかはもうライオンの足の形にして
これ綺麗だからかっこいいんだからね
別にもう本当に動物の体ってそんな感じじゃないんだけど
人間の創作しちゃうと
創作して椅子の足は机の足はライオンの足にするとかね
そういうのはあの切っちゃうんです
王様寄付したものだからね
捨てるわけにいきませんし
その代わりに あのもうものすごい価値が出てくる部分は
切ってしまっちゃうんです
これも丁寧に美しくではなくて
なんか何かが合って それもう壊してしまって
椅子だけ使うと そうしなさいと
それで決して使ってはいけない絨毯は捨てる
あの特別なんとかの鹿の毛で編む絨毯があるんです
動物を動物の毛を持ってきて
このクマの毛とかね いろいろクマの皮膚
皮とかね それすごく調整して
そういうのもない絨毯に使ったりする
それから特別なこの鹿か
あのヤギか分かりません
鹿と言いますけどね でも究極な高級だそうで
その皮膚の皮が で 毛があまりにも柔らかくて
それは捨てる まとめてゴミ箱
使わない で そう まああんまりおしゃれな椅子なんかも机なんかも使ってはいけませんだけど
でもあれはもういろいろ調整して価値のないものにすることはできます
まあそこはまあ仏教の後で発展した社会通としての文化でですけどね
まああの これ瞑想の意図は関係ないんですけど
やっぱりこの足を組んで座るっていう場合は
まあ何の問題もないということでね
足を組んで座れることを本当に上手にできるようになってくると
あの健康に体にもいいんですよ
椅子に座ってるよりは
で 血液もよく流れちゃうし
で 体の機能はうまくいくんですね
それからすっごく安定しているんですね
倒せませんね 足を組んでる人は倒すことってなかなか難しいんです
しっかりともう座ってるんだから
例えば椅子に座ってて
どんどん眠くなってくる
どんどんどんどんどんどんどんどん前に前に前に曲げたりするでしょうし
足をちゃんと組んで座ってると
眠くなっても こうどこまでで前に曲げるってことできなくなっちゃうんですね
やっぱり体立ったままで保たれます
そういうこともあるでしょうし
で そんなことそちらでは全然考えてない
ただ単に簡単単純で まあみんなやってることだから
足を組んで座れと それだけ足を組んで座りなさい
ニシーダリ・パッランカ・アープジットア
だから余計な解釈も要りませんね
右足上か左足上かとか
右手上か左手上かとかね
そう聞く人は瞑想やらない
昨日来た人の中で一人がいたんですね
私は手をこうして右右手が上です
けど まあまあ それはもうそちらの文化ですけど
日本では違いますから
そこを何かどういうことかと
怒ったんだけど 余計なこと聞くなと
ただ自然にやってくださいと
でも言ったんだけど この人はやらないんだと
どうせアホやと その通りでやらなかったんですね
よく見ると 2 3分瞑想 2 3
分やってみればね わかるのに
右手上か左手 そこは気になるんですね
自分がすごい頭いいと思ってるんですね
クソを食べてるんだから
これ前から食べるか後ろからどちらが食べる？クソはクソだからね
どちらの方が品格がいいんですか？正しいんですかと
そんなことに頭が行くとね
だからもうもう私も年だからね
相手にもしたくないし
もう気持ち悪いね とにかくもう
ちょっと論理的な人間だったら
ほんのちょっとの時間だからね
人を言う通りにやればな
なんもなんなんでしょうかね
ほんのちょっとの2 30
分のことで それでもその人言う通りにやらない
だから直れないほど頭が悪いんです
もう何も このひとかけらも智慧が発展してくるというひとかけらもないんだから
なんで人間に生まれたんですかと
だけど 一応もうやがてでも気が済むだろうと
さっさと行ったんですね
そんなこと何の意味もないんだと
で 論理的に言えば これしか方法ないんだと
だから呪文とかね いろんなこと
あれは全てインチキだと
嘘だと マントラやらいろいろ
あの こう右手上か左手上だけではなく
あんた方よくやってるでしょ？ムッドラ印を踏むとかね
あんなものは完璧に嘘だと
だからあっきりそこを置いておいてやってみなさいと
真言密教ではもう昔は衣でって
こうやっても見えないように
一般の人にいろいろ印を組んだりするんですね
まとめて粗大ゴミに入れたいんですね
自分がすごい頭いいと思ってるんですね
クソを食べてるんだから
これ前から食べるか後ろからどちらが食べる？クソはクソだからね
どちらの方が品格がいいんですか？正しいんですかと
そんなことに頭が行くとね
だからもうもう私も年だからね
相手にもしたくないし
もう気持ち悪いね とにかくもう
ちょっと論理的な人間だったら
ほんのちょっとの時間だからね
人を言う通りにやればな
なんもなんなんでしょうかね
ほんのちょっとの 二 三十分のことで
それでもその人言う通りにやらない
だから治れないほど頭が悪いんです
もう何も このひとかけらも知恵が発展してくるというひとかけらもないんだから
何で人間に生まれたんですかと
だけど一応もうやがてでも気が済むだろうと
さっさと行ったんですね
そんなこと何の意味もないんだと
で 論理的に言えば これしか方法ないんだと
だから呪文とかね いろんなこと
あれは全てインチキだと
嘘だと マントラやらいろいろ
あの まあこう右手上か左手上だけではなく
あんた方よくやってるでしょ？ムッドラ
印を踏むとかね あんなものは完璧に嘘だと
だからあっちにそこを置いておいてやってみなさいと
真言密教ではもう昔は衣でって
こうやって見えないように
一般の人にいろいろ印を組んだりするんですね
まとめて粗大ゴミに入れたいんですね
みんな 何の意味もないでしょうに
指がこうやった こうやった
こうしました こうしましたということで
もっと立派なこと 中国のちっちゃな女の子たちやるでしょうに
あの あのアクロバティックとかね
もう並の人間にできないことやってるでしょうに
そちらが意味があるんです
みんなすごいと これはこんな体っていうのはなんかまあ糸のように曲がっちゃうんだから
もう あれは意味があるんです
あれですもう中国人もすごい人間だっていうことは世の中も知ってるし
まあそれでいろいろ試合に出たりとかね
商売になってるんだから
こうやってこうやっとか
印を踏んだりすることでね
こうやったりとかね 意味がないんだよ
昔 仏像を作ったこの あの芸術家たちが
あの ただお釈迦様の写真を取ってきて
そこを作ったわけじゃなくて
あれは芸術作品だから
ブッダの内容というか中身をね
造形で表現できるかという
これは芸術の世界で それでいろいろ
まあこうやって阿倍ムッドラとかね
こういうムッドラとかね
まあこういうムッドラとか
それからこういうムッドラとかね
それはいくつあるんです
で 普通に作りにくい なんとかありますけどね
あの まあまあまあ こういうだからあの
あの あの 諸天宝輪の場合はね
あれは まあこういうこと
これはあまり出来が悪いんだけどね
あの でまあいろいろあの
決まりがあってね で あの
あるんですけどね だけどお釈迦様そんなことやったわけないでしょうに
ただ これは真理を解明すると
ということで この芸術家がそう思って作っただけ
そこでこうやって手を出すことは阿倍ムッドラというんですね
阿倍っていうのは安心しなさいよと
という このみんなに安らぎを与えると
まあただこれだけ 手を挙げてるだけ
でも今風に言えば来るなという意味なんです
せっかくお寺に行って本さんをお参りしようと思ったらこうしてるんだからな
ストップ まあでもあれすごい上手なことは普通我々だったらこうすることは来るなっていう意味でしょうね
それでも仏像を見るとそう感じないんですね
だから芸術家っていうのは大したもんだと
それからお釈迦様の耳っていうのは
この肩に触れてるでしょ
人間の顔だとあれほど気持ち悪いことはありますか
人の耳なんか肩に触れるまで伸ばしていると
あれすっごい気持ち悪いでしょう
じゃあ仏像を見てください
どっちも気持ち悪いかというと
あまりにも美しくて それは別にお釈迦様はそうあったわけじゃなくて
で 仏たちからこの彫刻家たちが芸術家たちが
いかにお釈迦様の心を表現するかっていうことなんですね
だからそれはやっぱり美術の世界で研究するべきであって
こうやったら人の煩悩をなくすんだとかね
観音様をお祈りする時は
まあなんかこんな感じで礼をするとかね
大日狙いの場合はまた何とか何とか感じでこうやるとかね
嘘のいいところでしょ
そんなことは だからそういう知識が頭に染み込んじゃうと
この科学的な仏教はもうあっち飛んでしまっちゃうんですね
だからヴィパッサナーの時はもう宗教はもう何の関係もないんです
もう智慧の世界にはそんなものは何も関係ないんです
科学と全く同じ もう単なるもうもう残酷に研究すればいいんです
ですから 智慧を得たければ
もう徹底的に自分をね
もう観察して見ていけばいいんですね
まあですから このパッランカがアウジッタということで飛んでしまっちゃったんだけど
それもどんなような足
左足上か右かとかね そういうことよりも
できれば足を組んで座れる
できなければそれはそれでいいんですけど
まあできるようになった方がいいかもしれません
次のことはウジュンカーヤンパニダーヤ
カーヤン身体はウジュンまっすぐにしてパニダーヤ置いておく
体をまっすぐにして パリムカンサティンウパッタピットワ
サティン自分のサティ気づくことをパリムカン前に持ってきて
いわゆるまあこの気づく
気づいておくんだっていうことも
なんとなくこのはっきりした仕事を通して
大雑把っていうことではなくて
サティを前に持ってきなさいと
だからなんとなくイメージで考えちゃうと
このサティをする 確認をするということは
なんかここら辺にある実際にあるある一つの仕事のような感じでしっかり持ってくるんですね
サティを前に持ってくるってどういう感じなんですか
だからそこはしっかりするっていうことなんですね
大雑把には瞑想するんだっていうことではなくて
例えば本を読む場合はこの本を読むと
しっかりしてるでしょ
これを読むという感じで
これをやるという このイメージとしてはサティが前にいるんだというイメージなんですね
僕は歩く瞑想よくやりますけど
どうしても足に行きますよね
それも前に持ってくる
そうそうそう うん もう他のことではなくて
足を感じることやと 具体的に持ってくる
そこを例えば足の場合はね
それ例えば一時間とかもうやり続けちゃうと
あまりにも具体的にやっちゃうと
どんどんもう足とかなんとかということではなくて
やっぱりある物体が動いている
その物体が動いている
また巨大にその物体につなげて
ある感覚が働いているという
この 2つが明確にどんどんどんどんなってくるんですね
足にしたっても体の一部ということではなくて
物体があって その物体が違うエネルギーが働いてきて
感覚というね それで動かしている
それで自分が上げたいと自分の意思もあって
あっちの感覚まで それ全部一つの働きで
足って物体が別の働いて
これナームルーパの分子ですか
これすごくしっかりわかってくるんですね
だから まあそうやって最初から具体的に足を観察するんだということにしてしまえば
で 次の次の方向まで智慧が発達していくんです
で この場合だけなんですけど
このパリムカンサティという言葉が出てくるのね
サティを前に持ってきてということはね
それは呼吸のことだから
もう一つは いつでも客観的に見るということは
この外から見ることなんですね
ですから 外から自分を見る
主観的に見るんじゃなくて
だからこちらでもこの客観的にというこの言葉なんですね
本当はこのあまりこの客観的主観的という言葉に合うパーリ語ないんです
で なぜかというと この客観的ということ自体がかなり幅広くて
たくさん専門用語があるんですね
専門用語によってちょっとニュアンスがそれぞれ変わっちゃうんですね
現代的な言葉でもたった 2つしかないんですけど
客観的 主観的と でも客観的な見方にもそもそもたくさんあるんです
主観にもいろいろあるでしょうと思いますけどね
そういうことだから はっきりしたパーリ語ではパーリ語ではね
まあ分かられる言葉がないんですね
まあ動詞の場合ありますけど
ですから この場合はただ簡単にパリムカンサティ自分の前にサティを持ってきてという
ですから この まあまあ
これから観察するんだと
まあこういう呼吸やらね
こういうものはまあこれからもうこれから観察スタートというふうな決めたら
まあそこはもうサティが前に来たことなんですね
それから そう サトーはアッササティ
その人は気づき 気づきながら
気づきがあって いわゆる感じながらということなんですね
気づきながらアッササティ
吸います 気づきながら吐きますと
私は 2  3回ぐらい深呼吸してみた見なさいというのは
やっぱり深呼吸する場合
気づかないと深呼吸できませんだからね
わざと意志を入れないで入れないと深呼吸できませんしね
ですから ちゃんとこういうことを吸うということ
吐くということ こういうことやと
ちゃんとまず気づいて吸ったり吐いたりする
ですから これは自然な呼吸だから
ディーガンワアッササントゥディーガンアッササミーティパジャナーティ
ディーガンワ もし長く長いければと長いであるならば
アッササントゥ いわゆる長く呼吸
もし長く吸ってるならば
長く吸ってるんだと理解する
明確にわかる これ長い呼吸だと
これは今長く吐いてるんだと
今短く吸ってるんだと
今短く吐いてるんだと
だからこのワという言葉でラッサンワアッササントゥラッサンアッササミーティパジャナーティ
もし自分の吸うことはラッサン短く短いであるならば
それは短い 短いんだと理解する
だからこちらでは呼吸瞑想っていうのはものすごい簡単単純で言ってますけど
呼吸瞑想自体またまあ大変それだけで瞑想システムできてますから
それは他の経典で書いてますけどね
こちらではまあほんのちょっとしか書いてないんですけどね
だから自然的な呼吸も何の理屈も使いません人だから深呼吸しなくちゃいけない
腹式呼吸しなくちゃいけないとか
そこをもうあまりにもひどいんですね
いろんな考え方で生きていようと思っちゃいますから
だから人間っておかしいんだから
まず概念作って 概念に沿って生命をコントロールしようとする
そうじゃなくて逆でしょうに
生命に沿っていろんなことをコントロールしなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だから今 現代人というのは服に合うように体いじるでしょうに
あれ すごい変でしょうに
体に合う服を買うんじゃなくて
服に合う体を作る すごく威張る
その上 そこでこのデザインの人々っていうのは結構頭おかしいでしょ
変人ばっかりでしょ そういう人々は自分の頭の妄想がね
これからどんな服作ろうかわからないんですね
そこで人間がそれに合うように
次にまた体作っちゃうんだから
だから自然 まあまあ進化の過程だからしょうがないんだけどね
環境に合うように体変化するんだと
これちょっと強引すぎなんですけど
逆にそういうことだから体変化しないんですね
逆なところ だからすごく悪いね
例えば今 電波障害 空気汚染
水は汚染していて その体に
その環境に我々の体が合わなきゃおかしいんです
電波汚染だからって言って
我々はもう電波遮断する何か檻を作って
その中で歩いたりすることはできないでしょうに
ですから まあいろんな電波が障害で受けても
まあ一応耐えられるぐらい体作らなくちゃいけないから
自然の汚染っていうのは
まあ 1 日にして起きるんだったらしょうがなくて
みんな死んじゃいますけど
放射能とかね そうでない場合はゆっくりなんですね
だからそのゆっくりだから
それこれから生まれる子供たちにはいくらでも時間があるんです
この環境に合うために
でもその能力は服に合うためにやってるんだから
環境に合わなくなっちゃうんです
だから病気だらけになってしまっちゃうんです
だからおかしいことをやらない方が
いいんです 普通 自然のままで自然に合わせてているんだったらね
体っていうのはまあ適当に変化はするんだけど
まあそこはまあそういうことを関係ない話で
ですから この場合は ただ座って
この知識 意識する世界能力をなんとなく自分の前の方に無声の感じに持ってきて
で 今長く吸ってるんだ
今長く吐いてるんだ 今短く吸ってるんだ
今短く吐いてるんだというふうな感じで見るということなんですね
私はということではないんですね
一応こちら私はという言葉が出ていますけど
で そうやって何か客観的に何か観察しているような感じで
呼吸コントロールすることはしないで
腹式か鼻 鼻先でやっているか
胸でやっているかとかね
そういうことをまるっきり気にしないで
背筋だけ伸ばして呼吸やればいいんです
で 次にサッバカーヤ パティサンウェーディ アッサ シッサ メティ シッカティ
サッバカーヤ 全ての体をパティサンウェーディ
理解しながら感じながら吸いますと
シッカティ 学ぶというか訓練を続けていく
訓練はそこなんです 腹式訓練ではなくて
この吸いますという吸ったところで
この体全体を感じられるぐらい
自分の感じる能力を増やしてみる
より頭は良くするということなんですね
理解能力を伸ばすと この体全体という場合は
ブッダガサ長老の解釈は違うんです
誰の解釈が正しいかとも私もわかりませんし
で ブッダガサ長老においては
ただ呼吸というそのものが体と解釈するんですね
呼吸を全部見なさいと
なんかちょっと納得いかないところもないわけじゃないんですね
呼吸というもの 全部見なさいと
で ちょっとどうかな わからないですから
一般的に体全体っていうことだから
もう体全体でいいんじゃないかなとね
で なんでそうなったかというと
この鼻先だけに集中して呼吸瞑想を教えていたんだから
それはこのサマーディを作るためには大変便利なんです
サマーディ統一状態を作るためには
この鼻の先だけの感覚だけ見て
瞑想するんで そうするといきなり体消えてしまっちゃうんですね
もう体に集中してないんだから
鼻の先だけに集中しているんですね
いきなりと言っても これ時間かかりますけど
まあどんどんどんどんどんどんどんどん瞑想して瞑想して訓練して訓練していくと
鼻の先だけ分かれるようになってきて
他のところは興味なくなっちゃう
座ってるか立ってるかということではなくて
鼻の先の方がすごく厳密に体験できるようになってくるんですね
で その場合は呼吸全部わからなくてはならないんですね
いわゆる呼吸が触れて中に行っちゃうでしょうね
中は感じません 外も感じます
ですから 呼吸というのはある一方の棒で考えちゃうと
空気そのものがね その一方の棒になってる空気がこうやって最後まで入っちゃう
この最後まで入って そこまでここで感じる
そこでこの空気の棒のようなものが
そこを鼻の先からこうやって出て
終わるまで出て行っちゃう
そこまでここで感じると
空気が始めて触れる 触れ始めて
どんどんどんどん触れて触れて触れていって止まって
それから出ていて 出ていて出ていてって止まるというそこである一つの空気そのものを一つの身体みたいな感じでね
で取ってるんですね そこでその瞑想の場合は
足とかお腹とかどこにも感じないんですね
自分で感じる能力をわざとわざと鼻の先だけにこの集中力を持ってきて
持ってきて だからうまく行った人の場合は
その人にとっては他のものはないように感じちゃう
もう もう 興味ないとそこに心がいかないんですね
それは呼吸のサマーディ瞑想の場合なんですね
ですから このサマーディ瞑想からヴィパッサナー瞑想の世界ですから
仏教論のテキストではやっぱりそうやって呼吸全体は体通って解析しちゃうんですね
で こちらどのように取ればいいかというのはもう決まることできませんだけど
私は一応結論としてではなくて
自分の意見として まあ普通な常識で体全体でいいんじゃないかなと
ですから 今長く吸ってますと言ったら
これ長く吸っているというエネルギーが体全体に行き渡っていく
それから その吐くエネルギーが体全体から入っていって
体から出ていくという
この結局エネルギーだからね
吸ったっていうことエネルギーだから体全体に行き渡っていくはずなんですね
振動したってもね どこか触ったらその振動がずっと先まで行くでしょう
だからそこを感じられるぐらい我々は敏感がないかっていうことなんですね
例えば今喋ったり いろんなことを考えたりすると
我々は呼吸はまるっきり感じないでしょうに
ですから 時々はほんのかすかな音でも感じるとかね
真夜中とか一人でいると微かな音でも感じる
そうやって人間はその時その時
いろんなものを感じたり感じなかったりする
今は私たちは外は全く静かなように感じるかもしれません
でも ほんのちょっと待って
じっと外に目を向けてみると
かなりうるさい いろんな音はあるでしょうに
ですから その集中力次第なんですね
ここでわざと呼吸というものを見ているんだから
吸うということは体で膨らむことだから
そのエネルギーは体全体に論理的には行くはずなんです
エネルギーが でも感じない
それでずっと感じて 感じて感じて感じていくと
この我々の感覚が鋭くなって敏感になって
いとも簡単に体全体で感じられるようになります
体全体で吸ってます 吐いてます
吸ってます 吐いてます
ということは感じられるようになります
今長く吸ってます 長く吸ってます
体全体で長く吸っていることを感じる
長く吐いて吐いてますと言ったら
体全体でそのエネルギーは感じられるようになる
そこに使っている言葉
シッカティ そこまで頑張ってみなさいと
シッカティっていうのは Learn という学ぶという言葉なんですけど
まあ実践しなさいと いわゆる感覚能力
感じる能力を育てるということなんですね
そこをステージ行ったところで
パッサンバヤンカーヤサンカーランアッサシッサーミーテシッカティ
カーヤサンカーランというのは体の
いろんな動きあります
体もなかなか大変なもので
いろんな部品が好き勝手にまとめないでいろんな動きをしているんですね
お腹は自分勝手に動きをする
頭は自分勝手にいろんな動きをするとかね
体のいろんな部品がいろんな好き勝手に動いたりはします
体っていうのはいつでも落ち着きない混乱状態にはあるんですね
そこで呼吸だけ見ていて
呼吸は体の全体で見ていて
見ていて 見ていて 体の中に生まれてくるいろんな感覚そのものを落ち着いてもらって
落ち着いてもらって 落ち着いてもらって
一つのリズムにまとめてもらう
そうやって体の他の動きはもう感じない
同時に体の中で混乱的ないろんな動きもない
全部一つのリズムにまとめてもらう
呼吸のリズム 時々あるでしょ
呼吸だけ見てると心臓は別にもっと早く回転してるんではないかと
そうなっちゃったら瞑想が混乱しちゃうんですね
心臓が早くドキドキドキドキドキしていて
呼吸はゆっくりと膨らんだり縮んだり膨らむ
これはもうドキドキドキドキドキ
それだけでも別々な行動でしょうに
心はあっち行ったりこっち行ったりあっち行ったりこっち行ったりするんだから
サマーディなんかもう生まれっこはないんですね
ですから 他の感覚を抑えておいて
体全体で呼吸を感じるようになって
それから体を落ち着いてもらう
体の機能 それでどうなるかというと
この呼吸という動き それははっきりと明確に理解することができるんです
それで呼吸瞑想は終わります
次にあるのはこのたとえですね
うーんと まあロクロですかね
なんかの誰かさんがたとえがあって
このロクロをやってる人は長く引くとかね
短く引くということはね
まあどういうことかとわかりませんね
はっきりは まあまあ お釈迦様はたとえで言ってるんだから
そこら辺よくあったことだと思いますけどね
まあおそらくなんかこの弓みたいなものに繋げてロクロを回すという場合はね
まあ長い短い 長い短いっていうことは出てきますけどね
私たちはそれをカンナだと思ってるんですね
木をね 平らにまっすぐにするときは
もうカンナで削るんですね
その時はもうさーっといっぺんに長く削るか
短く短くするかということをその場でその場で判断しながらやらなくてはならないんですね
とにかくわからない ですから
現代我々にとってはそのたとえはなかなかわからないことで
次にテキストでは次に行くべきところは
次の三ページにあるこの二百九十三ページですね
英文の二百九十三ページですけど
このテキストの イティアジャッタヴァーヤカーヤヌパッシーヴィハルティバヒッダーヴァーカーヤカーヤヌパッシーヴィハルティ
ふむ イティアッジャッタンワーカーイ
アッジャッタンっていうのは自分の中という意味です
で 自分の中の体 自分の体についてそのように見ていくんだと
バヒッダーワーカーイ
外の体でも 呼吸の場合は外の体でも他の人の呼吸かもしれません
自分の体もそうやって動いている
他の他の誰が見たっても同じこと
誰でも それだったら人の呼吸なんか観察はできませんだけどね
とにかくこれはこの一人一人瞑想についてはそれほど合わないんです
でも この観察の仕方としては正しいやり方なんですね
だから これは違うところで大変必要な見方なんです
内で見 内を見て 外を見て
両方を見るということ
だから どんな瞑想にも合うわけじゃないしね
私はどうやって人の呼吸は瞑想できますかね
できないでしょうに 瞑想だから自分でやることでしょうに
だから時々これは人の呼吸を瞑想するんだという人もいますけど
まあもう無責任な言葉だと思いますけど
まあ見た目ではやっぱり呼吸だから
自分の呼吸はアッジャッタであって
人の呼吸はバヒラ 外なんですけど
だからってどうやってそれ観察します？誰が自分のそばに寝てでもいるんだったらね
その人の前に座って まあ今長く吸って
今短く吸ってるとかね
とは観察できますよ でもどうやってその人の体全体を感じたりとかね
できないでしょうね そしたらそこはやっぱりよした方がいいんです
あまり考えないで 呼吸瞑想の場合は本当はそうではなくて
やり方っていうのはこの自分の集中力を中に入れる
中から呼吸を見る 中から膨らんでいる
縮んでいる この二つを見ていく
それでさらに外から観察する
外から縮んだり膨らんだりすること
そこを見方だからね 中から見るか
こちらから感じるかと
これは感じることだから
見るということではないんだからね
それによって我々のこの観察能力っていうのは抜群に成長するんです
やってみていくと この中から
まず中からやりやすいんだからね
中から膨らんでいること
縮んでいること それから外からもやってみると
これもうかなり時間かかりますよ
内から見る 外から見る
で 呼吸瞑想サマーディ
その場合はいきなり外から見るんです
中からではなくて ここら辺に集中して
今吸ってますと 今吐いてますと見るんです
それで空気が外にあるんだから
空気は観察できませんだからね
外から触れるものをね
空気と感じるんですね
それはサマーディ瞑想だから
ヴィパッサナー瞑想には入らないんですけどね
で ヴィパッサナー瞑想になっちゃうと
まあ一番やりやすいのはもう中から膨らんでいくこと
中から縮んでることを観察する
それから外から膨らんでいること
縮んでいること観察 それ両方上手にできたところで
中外という感覚を置いておいて
ただ膨らんでいる 縮んでいるということを一般的に観察する
それですっごくもう感覚能力っていうのはものすごく変わるんです
すっごく変わるんです
面白くないというところじゃないんです
すっごい観察能力 感覚能力変わるんだから結構違うんです
どう変わるかとは言ったらね
いきなり私に報告するんです
私はこういうふうに感じています
こういうふうに感じていますと
だから気持ち悪いんですね
騙される で そのように観察していて
それからサムデダンマヌパッシーワ
カーヤスミンヴィーハレティ
で サムデダンマ で ものの生起
現れて 現れていくこと
例えば椅子でも 例えば膨らみが
今膨らみが現れてきているんだと
縮みというものが現れてきたんだという
ある現象 自分の研究課題をもうはっきり明確に決めているんだから
呼吸という研究課題だからね
その呼吸というものが
吸吐という 2つに分けてあって
吸という現象が現れてきて
で 吐という それから次に吐くという現象が現れてきて
で ワヤダンマというのは消えていくという現象
それから吸という現象が現れてきて
それを終わってしまう
それから吐くという現象が現れてきて
それも終わってしまう
それから吸うという現象が現れてきて
それからまた吐くという現象が現れてきて
それ終わってしまう そうやって限りなく現象が一つの現象が現れてくる
で 消えちゃう でまたその代わりに全く違う現象が
吐くという現象が現れてきて
これまた消えちゃう で
消えたところにまた吸うという現象が現れてきて
堂々と現れてきて ゆっくりと消えてしまう
それでまた吐くという現象が堂々と現れてきて消えてしまう
そこにピントを合わせてくださいと
呼吸というよりも この呼吸にあるこの普遍的なそこら辺にピントを持って行ってくださいということになる
重点を そこでその人にもう
もう集中的に呼吸だけ見てるんだから
その人に実際する世界っていうのは
呼吸が 呼吸という現象あるんだと
それまた 2つに分けてみたら
吸うと吐くというやつがあって
吸が現れてきて消えちゃったら
吐くが出てきて消えて
また吸うが現れてきて消えちゃって
また吐くということが現れてきて消えていくという呼吸
という現象ですよと それで呼吸の研究は完璧なんです
ものすごい明確にやったことになるんです
何の間違いもなく だからワヤダンマヌパッシーワ
カーヤスミンヴィーハレティ
次にサムデワヤダンマヌパッシーワ
その体に沿いて まあそうやって両方現れて
また消えていって 現れてまた消えていってとか
両方をまとめて見ていくと
次の智慧っていうのはアッティカーヨーティワパナスサティパッチュパッティターホーティ
あ こんな体ですよと だからここで見るとこんな体ですよという場合は呼吸なんです
今ここで体と言ったのは呼吸なんです
だからカーヤ体なんですけど
アッジャッテーワカーエーバヒッダーワーカーエーというとちょっと困るんです
外の呼吸観察はできませんだからね
だからブッダの長老は一言葉にまとめようと思ったかもしれません
でもこちらでカーエーというのは
体というのはもうはっきりと呼吸のこと
ああ 呼吸という身体があるんだと
身体っていうのは単なるシステムということでね
別に実体という意味ではなくて
呼吸という機能があるんだと
それは現れては消える
現れては消えて現れては消える
だから膨らみ縮みで見たっても現れては消える
例えば膨らみは現れだったら縮みは消えるでしょうし
膨らみだけ見たら膨らみ自体が現れて消えていく
縮みだけ見ると縮みが現れては消えていく
綺麗さっぱり消えるでしょうに
膨らみと縮みっていうのはまるっきり正反対の感覚でしょ
まるっきり正反対の感覚だから
だから膨らみというエネルギーと縮みというエネルギーは随分も違う
方向も違う これだから白い黒いと同じなんです
白があって 次に黒があって
次に白があって 次に黒があるっていうような感じなんです
白いと黒いっていうのは随分違うでしょうに
正反対でしょうに だから白が消えると黒が出てきて
黒が消えると白が出てくると
それぐらいの理解でも
やっぱり一つの流れが
流れというか 一本の実体の流れがないんだと
そこに大した何のことなくてね
全く性質違う現象が交互に現れていく
現れていくということなんですね
智慧の世界っていうのは
ここはまあわかってきます
そこでサティという気づくこと
感じること 観察する能力ってのはアッティカーヨ
そういう体があるんだと
そういう機能があるんだっていう
そんな機能だと 呼吸というものはというぐらいの
ほんのそれぐらいの智慧なんです
それぐらいって言ったって
これすごい智慧なんです
なんでそれぐらいの智慧かというかと
それはこの宗教の世界で言ってるトンデモない経費承諾的なとてつもない何とかという嘘の智慧ではありません
私は神とよく対話しているんだとかね
幽霊 お化けやらなんだかんだ言わ見える見えるんだと
それで他の人はなんかあれ？とびっくりするだけで
それが自分がなんか得したような感じ
錯覚してたり そんなことではなくて
これは膨大な智慧なんですけど
別に言葉にすれば まあ呼吸っていうのはそんなもんだよというぐらいの意味になっちゃうんです
ヤーワデーワニャーナマッターヤ
これはほんのちょっとの智慧
得るだけと この呼吸瞑想で
これほんの少々のこの智慧を得るだけですよ
パティッサティマだと落ち着くんですね
ちょっと落ち着きが生まれるんですよ
それだけじゃなくてアニッストーチビヘルティ
あんまりとらわれないように
世の中に ビヘルティナキンチローケウパーディティ
何も別にとらわれる とらわれなくなっちゃうんですね
何を取っちゃえばいいんですかね
呼吸の膨らみ取っちゃえばいいんだ
縮み取っちゃえばいいんです
何もとらわれなくなっちゃうんです
すぐ消えちゃいますからね
まあそんなもんだからということで
もうとらわれないような感じに心が育てていくんです
それは一つの実践方法ですと
エーワンピコビッカエビク
カヤ・ニパッシーラでこのA1P
このようにもできるんだと
体の観察またあるんだということなんですね
まあこういう方法もありますよと
やってみたらどうですかという感じでA1Pアピールしてるんですね
また見ようとすれば また他の方法もあります
体をね で それは後にします
まあ全部我々現代人にできるわけじゃないんだけど
あのいくつかできるものはあります
まあ次にあるものも あの三十二に体をね
あの分解して見る瞑想でね
はい それで終わり  [効果音]